- Hello.
- Are we just starting?
- Welcome to our TV show.
(upbeat music)
- (bleep), marry or kill?
Pizza, alcohol, John Krasinski.
- (laughing) Pizza, alcohol.
I would (bleep) a pizza.
- Me, too.
- I would marry John Krasinski.
- 'Cuz he's a sweetheart.
- Mm-hmm.
- And I'd kill alcohol.
- Yep.
- Have you ever pretended you weren't
Kristen Wiig when asked?
- All the time.
Instead of recognizing me,
they always tell me I
look like Kristin Wiig
or like I look like someone
that was like on SNL or something.
And then I just say, "Oh yeah,
I get that all the time."
- I was on vacation with my family
and a woman came up to me.
The woman said, "Hi, can I
find a picture of Ben Stiller?"
(Kristen laughing)
(romantic music)
And I was like, "No, I'm not Ben Stiller."
- Do you do any vocal
exercises to help prepare
your voice before scenes?
- Yes, I do!
(Kristen laughing)
No, what I generally do is just come in,
do all of the screaming first,
so by the end of a five
or six hour session,
there's nothing there.
- Wait, for real?
- No.
- Oh.
- Do you and your character in the movie
have anything in common?
- Real skinny legs (chuckling).
I'm just kidding.
We both drive.
- Are you a spy?
- No.
- Hmm. (Kristen chuckling)
- [Kristen] Have you ever
used your celebrity status
to get you into something?
- Yes, all the time, it's all I do.
But, more importantly,
the look on someone's face
when they know that they aren't
as important as you are is priceless.
I love it!
What's your craziest tabloid rumor
that you have ever read about yourself?
- Oh, my God, they're all crazy!
I went to a restaurant
with my friend's parents
and it was very loud for them,
so we asked to move.
According to the papers, I hated
my seat, (thunder crashing)
so I asked to be moved three times
and I left my bag at the table.
And when they returned it to
me, I yelled at the manager
and told them it was their fault.
(both laughing)
They just make shit (bleep) up, stuff up.
- Be careful what you say.
- And what you read.
- It can have consequences.
- And what you spread.
(upbeat music)